[Musica]
questo è il tempo delle donne lo avevate
notato questo è il tempo delle donne
viviamo nel tempo delle donne le donne
sono protagoniste di questo tempo nel
mondo occidentale oggi le donne sono
dappertutto
le donne sono protagoniste nella società
nel mondo del lavoro nella politica
nelle istituzioni
nell'arte nella cultura nella scienza le
donne sono protagoniste non c'è problema
questione progetto che non venga
analizzato pensando al punto di vista
delle donne all'impatto di genere alla
prospettiva di genere all'effetto dal
punto di vista femminile le donne quindi
sono protagoniste di questo tempo ma le
donne non sono soltanto protagonista di
questo tempo
le donne sono anche vittime di questo
tempo
o meglio vittime di questi tempi i tempi
delle donne non sono i tempi degli
uomini le donne hanno abdicato al loro
tempo per donarlo agli altri il concetto
della relatività del tempo della fisica
della fisica teorica si concretizza
perfettamente nella vita delle donne il
tempo delle donne non è il tempo degli
uomini le donne sono divise tra tanti
tempi il tempo della vita familiare il
tempo della procreazione
il tempo dell'allevamento della cura dei
figli il tempo del lavoro alle donne si
chiede tantissimo
si chiede di essere sempre in forma di
riuscire a soddisfare i tempi degli
altri se chi è vero ricco chi è la
persona felice è la persona che ha del
tempo del tempo per se stesso del tempo
per donare agli altri
beh diciamo che le donne sono povere di
tempo per se stesse le donne hanno poco
tempo per loro perché donano il loro
tempo agli altri alle donne si chiede
tempo se dobbiamo descrivere la vita di
una donna lavoratrice madre magari di un
figlio piccolo
come la descriveremo che cosa vi viene
in mente
noi siamo sempre di corsa la nostra vita
è una corsa è una corsa contro il tempo
un incastro continuo
siamo vittime della mancata
conciliazione dei tempi siamo vittime
della difficile conciliazione a volte
impossibile conciliazione dei tempi
siamo vittime del multitasking a noi si
chiede di essere madri perfette di
essere il fuoco la il centro del
focolare domestico il fulcro della
famiglia tradizionale e non tradizionale
ma noi si chiede anche di essere
lavoratrici brave bravissime di essere
competitive con i colleghi uomini di
sfondare la barriera di cristallo di
arrivare ai vertici
quindi alle donne si chiede tantissimo
ma le donne non si dà altrettanto le
donne le donne moderne le donne del
mondo occidentale le donne protagoniste
si trovano in una situazione difficile
siamo donne in bilico spesso costretti a
delle scelte drammatiche rinunciare a
una parte di noi rinunciare all'idea
della procreazione o posticiparla e
sappiamo che posticiparla troppo a volte
significa rinunciare e dall'altro lato
volte sacrificare il lavoro sacrificare
la carriera siamo in bilico donne in
bilico una dimensione individuale di
profonda drammaticità alle donne si
impone una scelta una scelta drammatica
che non è la scelta che si impone agli
uomini siamo quindi sempre sottoposte ad
una pressione molto forte che viviamo in
una dimensione individuale ma questo è
l'errore non è una dimensione
individuale
in realtà questo è un problema
collettivo perché il problema
individuale diventa un problema
collettivo nel momento in cui ha un
impatto con l'eti perché le donne sono
il fulcro del mercato del lavoro
aumentare l'occupazione in questo paese
significa aumentare l'occupazione
femminile è l'occupazione femminile che
più bassa di quella maschile anzi in
italia l'occupazione femminile è tra le
più basse nei paesi europei
la disoccupazione femminile è più bassa
di quella maschile
il tasso di inattività femminile è bassi
è altissimo tasso di inattività
significa che le donne hanno rinunciato
a sperare
il tasso di inattività è un indice di
sfiducia delle donne del mercato el
indice del fatto che le donne sono
sfiduciate o sono state espulse dal
mercato o non ci sono entrate ma hanno
rinunciato a cercarlo
è un dato di profonda tristezza il dato
di inattività e allora aumentare
l'occupazione del paese significa
aumentare l'occupazione femminile
puntare sulle donne rilanciare il lavoro
delle donne dall'altro lato guardiamo
però questo paese questa dimensione
individuale di drammatica scelta ha
portato a un bassissimo tasso di
natalità il tasso di natalità in questo
paese è tra i più bassi al mondo ben al
di sotto del livello di rimpiazzo
siamo un paese che non cresce poco
lavoro e pochi figli troppo pochi figli
troppo poco lavoro c'è un problema c'è
un corto circuito che fare
e allora vediamo che quella dimensione
di drammaticità individuale diventa una
dimensione che hanno proiezione
collettiva una proiezione importante per
il nostro paese non è quindi un affare
individuale è un affare collettivo è un
affare che a che fare con lo stato è un
affare di stato e la politica che si
deve occupare di questo è la politica
che deve puntare sulle donne da
giuslavorista vi dico
e vero che ci sono molte tutele nel
mercato del lavoro il diritto del lavoro
prevede molte tutele nel mercato per le
lavoratrici ma quali lavoratrici le
lavoratrici subordinate le tutele sono
fondamentalmente incentrate nel rapporto
di lavoro subordinato ma guardiamoci
intorno come il mercato del lavoro oggi
il mercato del lavoro sta cambiando non
è più soltanto il lavoro subordinato
anzi è il diritto del lavoro però si è
dimenticato di una parte delle
lavoratrici
autonoma e le libere professioniste le
lavoratrici a bouchehr la famosa gig
economy ha quasi polverizzato il
rapporto di lavoro si è trasformato ci
sono tanti tanti tipi di lavori e la
maggior parte di questi non sono
tutelati
le lavoratrici allora sono divise tra
chi ha tantissime tutele chi ne ha poche
ma che chi ha tante tutele in realtà non
è
non ha la fortuna di poter fare con
serietà delle scelte perché perché le
troppe tutele sono un boomerang
molte volte le troppe tutele si
trasformano in un boomerang
e accade allora che un datore di lavoro
invece che assumerà una lavoratrice che
si porta dietro una dote di pacchetto di
tutele assume un lavoratore un uomo
proprio per evitare quelle tutele e
allora bisogna fare qualcosa bisogna
cambiare il punto di vista bisogna
cambiare la prospettiva
dobbiamo partire da una constatazione
le donne in questo paese rappresentano
un pezzo del welfare
le donne hanno sostituito lo stato in
tutta una serie di situazioni
le donne si occupano dei figli li
allevano si occupano degli anziani li
accudiscono le donne arrivano dove lo
stato non arriva
le donne sono un pezzo di welfare e
allora se la politica è lo stato deve
investire sul welfare
e se le donne sono un pezzo di welfare
lo stato deve investire sulle donne
investire sulle donne significa metterci
i soldi significa scommettere sulle
donne scommettere in particolare sulle
donne giovani sulle nuove generazioni
per cambiare il paese per far andare
avanti il paese come fare come
scommettere sulle donne
io voglio lanciare un'idea perché a
perdersi lancia un'idea
un'idea che può essere un progetto o può
essere presa come una provocazione
un'idea che però è un'idea
concretizzabile si parla di reddito
minimo
io
darei un reddito minimo di maternità un
reddito minimo di maternità alle donne
che rinunciano ad una parte della loro
attività lavorativa per l'accudimento
dei figli e soltanto per un tempo
limitato
magari fino ai 13 anni di vita dei
minori rinunciare una parte del tempo di
lavoro per l'allevamento e la
procreazione dei figli un reddito minimo
di maternità che consenta alle donne a
prescindere dalla tipologia di contratto
di lavoro subordinate autonome voucher
libere professioniste a prescindere un
reddito di dignità per consentire le
donne di non essere sempre sottoposte a
questa drammatica scelta di poter
prendersi una pausa lavorativa ma
restando con un piede nel mercato per
l'accudimento dei figli e per un
accudimento dei figli che non deve
essere limitato i primi anni di vita dei
figli perché noi italiani non abbiamo la
stessa cultura delle donne nord europee
delle donne e nord americane
la donna italiana vuole essere una madre
italiana vuole esserci nella vita dei
propri figli
vuole essere protagonista vuole essere
un punto di riferimento vuole esserci e
allora dobbiamo consentire alle donne di
soddisfare questa esigenza di fare
questa scelta
un reddito minimo di maternità che però
imponga le donne in cambio di rimanere
nel mercato con formazione perché la
formazione all'investimento per se
stessi un investimento per il futuro è
un investimento per ritornare a lavorare
dopo il periodo di pausa
oppure con una serie di attività
lavorative dobbiamo prendere il buono
per esempio che c'è nella gig economy
nella collaborative economy nella scena
indie economy il lavoretto la
flessibilità negativa può essere voltata
il positivo se vista come conciliativa
una forma di conciliazione che consenta
la lavoratrice che decide che per i
primi tredici anni di vita dei suoi
figli si occuperà principalmente di loro
di tenere un piede dal mercato di non
mollare completamente in modo da essere
facilmente poi rimessa in un circolo di
produzione
ecco questa può essere uno spunto
un'idea
vorrei aggiungere ancora una cosa
accanto questo dovrebbe esserci anche
una contribuzione figurativa aggiuntiva
che sopperisca alle carenze contributive
della lavoratrice che si sacrifica in
questo periodo di vita perché dobbiamo
pensare alla pensione
e allora se esiste la contribuzione
figurativa aggiuntiva per esempio per i
lavoratori usuranti
io la prevederei anche per le donne
l'usura non sarebbe data dal lavoro ma
dal doppio dal triplo lavoro magari in
proporzione al numero dei figli allevati
ecco allora che si investirebbe in modo
concreto si darebbe uno strumento
concreto un reddito minimo di maternità
una contribuzione figurativa aggiuntiva
lo stato ci dovrebbe mettere quindi
soldi ma consentirebbe in questo modo le
donne di fare il salto ma anche il paese
potrebbe fare il salto
perché abbiamo capito che solo le donne
la chiave di volta del sistema sono le
donne che possono far aumentare
l'occupazione
sono le donne che possono aumentare la
sostenibilità del welfare e sono le
donne che possono far crescere il paese
in termini di popolazione
naturalmente bisognerebbe sperimentare
queste misure dove per esempio nelle
pubbliche amministrazioni
ma non solo bisognerebbe coinvolgere le
imprese le imprese che con
responsabilità sociale si vogliano far
carico di questo di dare delle occasioni
di lavoro le donne delle occasioni di
lavoro anche flessibile molto flessibile
con incentivi alle imprese che decidono
di rappresentare uno strumento per le
donne per non perdere completamente il
contatto col mercato questa potrebbe
essere un'idea per far fare il salto
un'idea per limitare la disoccupazione
femminile per aumentare l'occupazione
femminile per sconfiggere l'inattività
femminile e per portare all'inclusione
delle donne che decidono in parte per
una parte della propria vita di
dedicarsi principalmente alla famiglia
ai figli ma senza rinunciare alle loro
aspirazioni di indipendenza economica di
carriera di futuro
e poi questo potrebbe anche servire per
far ritrovare
la voglia di natalità grazie
[Applauso]